why are we spending our time in
philosophy of science when we as science
scientists spend too much time in
philosophy of science we have failed and
one of my concerns is is that with all
of the ink spilled on what is science
what is a science what is a theory what
is a hope what is a prediction that's
what happens when people aren't able to
do good science for a long period of
time so here's the point over in biology
space we swear that evolution when we
say it's just a theory we don't mean
anything less it's as close to saying
its effect as we ever get right it has
been so thoroughly demonstrated to be
accurate that we are treating it as a
fact until we discover something that
dislodges it like this is all a
simulation and evolution was put in it
to see what we would think right
something like that so evolution is as
close to a fact as we get and we call it
a theory my point would be at the point
that your work predicts things in the
world that lead us to understand that it
is at least highly accurate and maybe
the final step in our quest to figure
out how the universe works then it
becomes a theory and there's only ever
one theory at a time right but the
problem is over in physics because
physics people are sloppy about this
language you've got people string
theorists engaged in string theory and
the thing is their work doesn't even
rise to the level of hypothesis they'll
say things like it's not a theory it's a
program but that's not my point it's
actually yeah Phillips philosophy of
science wise string theory is an
interpretation kit I want to try to say
something a little bit more horrible
okay why are we spending our time in
philosophy of science when we as science
scientists spend too much time in
philosophy of science we have failed and
one of my concerns is is that with all
of the ink spilled on what is science
what is a science what is a theory what
is a whole
what is a prediction that's what happens
when people aren't able to do good
science for a long period of time no no
I believe you are making a mistake and
by the way you make an excellent point
about what you call desperation physics
so I believe you are conflating I think
that may have been Powell Eastern well
you and Hallie have done very well with
this one but in any case desperation
physics is real I'm well familiar with
it
philosophy can become another version of
desperation physics or desperation
whatever science you want to talk about
it is not inherently that and so my
point would be you actually don't need
to spend a lot of time in philosophy of
science space but you need to spend
enough time and that in effect what
you've got in physics is you have the
string the so-called string theory
community which is effectively like all
of the suitors and other lowlifes in the
in the in the manor right and Odysseus
is coming home to liberate the manor and
save Penelope right the point is the the
coming home the stringing the bow the
saving Penelope is actually done with
the philosophy that says these people
are not legitimate here how do we know
because they have dressed up a notion
that maybe if we're generous is
interpretation they have dressed it up
as if it has the power of a theory it
doesn't even want rise to the level of
hypothesis but they're claiming it's a
theory these people are illegitimate and
so anyway I think that the amount I mean
you know that took three sentences four
sentences and the amount of power that
comes from recognizing why are we taking
this as seriously as a hypothesis or a
theory when it doesn't rise to that
level so let me just sort of say this
somebody set up a 24/7 chat room
facility on on the discord platform for
the portal community and when I pop in
by you know some some means by which I'm
quiet and I listen to what people are
talking about
a huge amount of the time they're
talking about is their free will are
there many worlds is something a
scientific hypothesis what I'm actually
interested in is to tell them these are
very expensive conversations that are
gonna take a tremendous amount of your
life
because you're going to assume that
there's more to this and quite honestly
you and I can be in different places my
feeling about this
is science is the totality of things
that have worked to produce fairly
reliable knowledge and at the end of the
day I believe that this is about taste
and about not wanting to be thwacked you
know in general most musicians have a
pretty clear idea about the hierarchy of
musicianship music is a very large space
it's not linearly ordered I'm not going
to pretend that we all you know have the
same favorite guitarists but most of the
time you can say you know Hillary Hahn
is one of the greatest violinists in the
world and everybody knows it and when
science is working we don't spend a lot
of time saying is this science we spent
a lot of time talking about is the
science is this settled when we're in
politics space when the field is
stagnated when there's a dispute in
which people refuse to say that logic or
data adjudicated and this may be
different for evolutionary theory in
physics but from my perspective I don't
enjoy being dragged into the demarcation
problem by people who want to say oh
you're a consequentialist or I actually
I'm coming here compatible i I'm from an
EOP Parian perspective it's like oh is
that are you telling me that you don't
do work yeah I don't I don't think I'm
telling you what you think I'm telling
you okay because the other part of this
riff is this is not supposed to be
scientists having this discussion yeah
but the scientists and like we've been
so dead for so long in what I care about
it's it's all dead I mean you've got an
entire Academy for wintered evolutionary
theory stuff
1976 pretty much not entirely but pretty
much yeah and pretty much in some sense
the kind of theoretical physics that I
weep over and gives me jitters stopped
around 1973 okay now my point would be
somehow we civilization subsidizes a
certain number of philosophers including
a certain number of philosophers of
science who are confused
for the most part into thinking that
their job is to talk to each other right
rather than to adjudicate what
constitutes science on the basis of
rules that are actually pretty well
understood and so I am NOT arguing that
we should be spending our time on this
but I'm arguing that their failure means
that a small amount of investment in
just getting our terminology even
straight so that when we make a claim we
are you know when physicists use the
word theory right for a hypothesis
they upend biologists who are saying
actually when we say Darwinism is a
theory we need something very close I
appreciate but you have to understand
people get into this argument over
Darwinism because they're afraid of its
information god yes okay I have a
different problem which is that in
general when physics isn't moving people
aren't getting more adventurous as to
who they're listening to they're staying
with the same Pope's sure so I could
turn to Karl Popper yeah or I could turn
to Ludacris and I don't know whether
you're familiar with the lyrics to the
song get out the way
now of course okay so my feeling is you
should say them for my audience who may
be somewhat less familiar
[Music]
I'm an old guy I can't remember the
lyrics exactly however my feeling is
strongly that we should be following
Ludacris rather than Karl Popper because
I don't have time for this
no you do have time for it for the
following reason that it's a time-saver
now we are wasting time here but that's
not well that's not but I my point is
you've got suitors in the manner to
string the bow string the [ __ ] boat
single to boy but stringing the bow
involves just saying hey you string
theorists you have an interpretation
you're not theorists there was a guy
named julian schwinger who was fineman's
rival and came up with his version of
what we call renormalization theory to
get answers out of quantum
electrodynamics and he had an epigram
for a book that he had to write because
nobody was taking him seriously and the
epigram was if you can't join them beat
the beat them yeah mm-hmm so my feeling
is is that I could spend the rest of my
life trying to get their attention and
saying oh pretty please listen to this
thing that I've got I'm also just sick
of them I mean I'm just I'm sick of the
critique I'm sick of the discussions I'm
sick of the same people getting trotted
out over and over again I'm bored sure
and we're all bored and so my feeling is
let's do non boring things right but
your work okay I still don't get it we
will get there hopefully but your work
in the end will predict things in the
fuze physical universe that will allow
us to tell whether or not you got it
right well when you say you got it right
the most important person in this
regards is not Karl Popper is probably
Dirac in his 1963 Scientific American
article where he specifically points to
the instantiation of a theory which is
effectively not only the suit but how it
has been tailored okay so you could have
a suit that has been Mis tailored and it
will not agree with experiment the way
the suit will not fit the person who's
intended to wear it on the other hand
that doesn't tell you anything much
about the suit it tells you about the
tailor so when you have an invalidation
part of the problem is is that you've
been validated the instance oh rather
than the class believe me for one thing
one of the reasons that I spend time in
philosophy of science land is that I
believe that all of the things that we
learned from the simpler fields do not
apply well to biology because the
complexity causes you to falsify true
things on the basis that that complexity
always provides edge cases which don't
agree and so if you take a very narrow
PAP aryan view you constantly think
things that are actually true or false
and this actually dovetails well with
popper himself who initially was not a
fan of adaptive thinking well and strong
prepare and miss readings of popper but
again my point is you are in a luxurious
position let's say with your telomere
theory and with the trade-offs and the
instantiation of antagonistic pleiotropy
as we discussed in episode 19 which is
the point is okay I just predicted
something from first principles inside
of molecular biology using only
evolutionary arguments so fu mm-hmm
right right exactly whew is fun because
he doesn't want it I don't love having
another philosophy of science I'd rather
talk about do we have the ability to
validate to explore to refine and again
you know I want I talk around science
all the time either we're talking about
pedagogy we're talking about what is it
good for in technology we're talking
about does it play by the rules we're
talking talking about everything other
then the mind-bending gut-wrenching
life-affirming soul elevating stuff
that'll get you high as a kite so I
would rather spend time on like the
majesty of the world than talking about
some goddamn philosopher of science and
whether or not I doubted my eyes and
crossed my teeth totally yeah but I
think your string theory community is
busy razzle-dazzle
with something that doesn't really merit
their they are so weak at this point it
is so past their sell-by date and not
because of the string theory it is the
string theory program which is let me
tell you don't worry we've got this
everyone else is an idiot we're smart
and anything else that anybody says
we're gonna declare as string theory
anyway if it's true so we got this my
feeling is you just wasted people's time
depending upon how we count based in
people's lives you wasted crews lives
careers you spent the entire credibility
budget of the theoretical physics
community on a baby-boomer vanity
project move over it's enough totally
and I don't know if you would agree with
this exactly but I would say look the
reason that this happens in every field
and it's completely maddening with the
strings theorists but it's not totally
unique is that there is no mechanism
whereby a school of thought that has run
out of power to explain new things can
be dislodged right the fact that the
grant money keeps coming in or the jobs
keep getting weirder there is something
which is money like for example there
was a death of a very rich person in
Chicago which I think was left at the
Poetry Foundation right so hundreds of
millions became available remember
poetry yeah okay if you had hundreds of
millions to disintermediate string
theory you could do it in an afternoon
sure but my point would be the way to
deal with this so it doesn't keep
happening is on the front end and
frankly I'm not even sure I didn't get
this from you but if instead of allowing
the field the school of thought that is
the most promising at the moment to take
over the field at which point it becomes
impossible to dislodge fails if you kept
the second-best school of thought alive
at all times so at the point that a
school of thought has failed it has its
natural replacement ready to go nobody
in a better position but let's let's be
it we're gonna end up in one more of
these
diversion discussions which I can't
stand but
here's the real deal with respect to the
string theorists were smarter than the
general relativists they were more
creative
string theory gave them some place to
demonstrate that they were smarter and
more creative okay yep as a result the
smart creative people went into an area
that turned out not to work now it's not
to say that some portion of it won't
will not be salvageable because it was
real work of a mathematical type but
part of the problem is how do I figure
out how to rationalize giving money to
people who are not as good as the top
people who've all rallied around
something uh-huh and so you have a
chicken and egg problem now let me just
say very clearly that this is not this
is like a peer-review problem this is a
science is social this is like selecting
for people with high emotional
intelligence some of us have high
emotional intelligence across a fair
spectrum and then it may be limited
somewhere else but we try not to use our
emotional intelligence when we're doing
science because it screws up our science
because in fact science isn't about like
anything that you want to pre assign it
to sometimes it works in teams sometimes
the team is the problem it's whatever
goddamn works and in essence being able
to say shut up to people who have like a
no [ __ ] policy I keep hearing about
our department as a no [ __ ] policy
it's like great you wouldn't participate
it in 20th century physics next you know
let's just let's just say it straight
you know what policy projected over a
past that we all know who the heroes
were oh my god Newton was mean to me you
know now he doesn't have a job yeah okay
well you've just showed us I I would not
send my child to a university that
announced that it had a no [ __ ]
policy on the faculty I might say I
don't want to tolerate assholic behavior
yeah or unfair behavior sure but like
hard nosed yeah no I mean you've been
making this point forever first place I
heard you make it was with reference to
medicine and your point was very
frequently the doctor you
aunt is an ornery son of a [ __ ] that
they're the people who will end up with
our first child was delivered by the
ornery son of a [ __ ] in a OBGYN
practice who saved us from the doctor we
loved yeah give me the son of a [ __ ] no
exactly no the person the person who
makes sense tells you what's really
going on I don't have to have tea with
that person I got my kid home from the
hospital safe
[Music]